hey you guys flickers of fear time
this time around talking about one that
uh just kind of came to shutter not too
long ago this is actually a very very
recent
movie uh came out 2021 at least that was
the date that was on it so i'm
why why should i question that i don't
know uh but yeah so this is the
apparently the directorial debut of a
woman named korin of faith
this is actually a british film and it's
called the power
now when i went to research this movie i
discovered that there is also another
movie i believe it's an
indian movie it's in hindi and it is
also called the power and it also came
out in 2021 so
don't get confused it's like just two i
don't know if that one's any good
because i haven't seen it
but uh this is the british one that i'm
talking about that's on shutter i don't
know if it's on the uk shutter i imagine
it probably is because it's a british
film
but it's on the american shutter as well
and i decided i would give it a watch so
this movie is set in 1974
and apparently around this time i had
heard of this before like you know
historically but i didn't know a great
deal about it but i guess like from late
1973 to early 1974
there were some disputes between uh
labor unions and the government over
you know various coal things uh you know
and that was kind of like a lot of
uh you know the the things that supplied
power you know to uh much of the public
so i guess during this several month
period
there were all of these sort of rolling
blackouts like they would uh turn off
everyone's electricity
at night like usually in the middle of
the night uh just to conserve
electricity
that's the time period that we're
looking into here so the title
the power you know is talking about the
electricity being off
uh obviously too but uh as usually
happens in these kind of situations it
also has kind of a double meaning which
we'll get into in a little bit
so the main character of this story
is a young nurse named valerie or val
she's kind of i guess she's pretty fresh
out of nursing school
this is her first job uh she was
a an orphan she you know she didn't know
who her parents were she grew up
in this um you know kind of an orphanage
or whatever that's in this sort of
real uh poor neighborhood so her first
job
is working at this uh infirmary a
hospital
in this same neighborhood and she's a
very
but she's kind of a mousy character
she's very quiet she's very by the book
she's
you know she's a good girl
quintessential and um
she really really feels like she went
into nursing because she seemed like she
genuinely wanted to
help the human race in general and she
really wants to help poor people in her
neighborhood where she grew up um
particularly because as i said she had
grown up an orphan herself so she knew
the
of the hardships that a lot of other
people had and she seemed very
good-hearted so she wants to kind of
give something back to her own
neighborhood her own community so she
starts working at this hospital
now the very first day that she gets
there uh
the matron who's kind of a hard ass a
little bit
um kind of takes a disliking to her but
i guess according to what everybody else
says there it's like she doesn't really
like anybody either
but she's like a big kind of stickler
for the rules and she's basically says
to val it's like you know you [ __ ] up
one time and
you know you're out on your ass we have
like tons of other people that could
work here so
quit your bitchin basically she doesn't
say that exactly but you know there's
kind of a lot of stuff at the beginning
where
she's trying to you know she's trying to
do really well this is her first job
like i said she's very excited about
getting to work in this field because
it's kind of like her dream field
and uh she very quickly begins to
realize not only because the matron is
kind of
you know shitty and brusque toward her
but also
she sort of very quickly learns her
place on the totem pole i guess because
other people that work there are sort of
you know the other nurses they're not
terrible people but they're just kind of
like dismissive and it's like oh god
this job it's like such a slog
it's like you know it's just cleaning up
piss and [ __ ] and vomit all day and it's
like i wish i could do something else
and so
she's kind of at odds with them a bit
because she
genuinely wants to seems to want to help
people and she thought that other
people in the nursing profession would
also want to help people and she's
finding out that's not the case
um and another thing too is that she
basically
finds out that the doctors are
essentially treated like
you can't question them you can't really
talk to them i think even the matron
says something to her to the effect of
they they're communicating above your
level so like you know what i mean like
don't talk to them unless
you're spoken to or whatever now without
really
meaning to she sort of breaks this rule
on the first day
because there's this doctor and i guess
that
she had seen him uh at some point he had
give he had given like a lecture or
something
in one of her classes or something and
he had said something
in his speech that sort of resonated
with her
so i guess when she sees him on the ward
i think his name is dr fisher if i'm
remembering it correctly
she sees him on the ward so she decides
that she's going to
just ask him about it and say oh you
know i saw your lecture and i agreed
with it and you know we should do this
that the other because it seemed like he
was really interested
in the same things that she's interested
in her main
focus of interest is uh the relationship
between health and poverty because as i
said this is a very economically
depressed area that she grew up in and
that she's now working in
so because she's speaking to the doctor
and he's actually quite
you know he's very young so he's not he
doesn't seem like quite as much of a
dick as like a lot of these older
doctors that are like oh
the nurses they're just so beneath us
and we can't even like stain to speak to
them or anything
so he kind of is like okay well you can
stay on the ward with me
and you know what do you think is wrong
with this little girl and you know so he
kind of like gets her to open up to him
now the matron sees this gets pissed off
and the fact that the matron
feels that val has sort of undermined
her authority on the very first day
means that she wants to punish her a
little bit so she's like well basically
you're gonna stay on for a whole another
shift
and you're gonna do the overnight shift
and as i mentioned
earlier this was a time when there were
rolling blackouts
now obviously some of the people in the
wards like people that were comatose or
you know babies or things like that
can't be moved
so they said generally what we do is if
they're going to do a blackout on
in this area on this particular night
we'll move most of the patients to this
other nearby hospital however
we do have to have you know the neonatal
the you know the babies still have to be
here the comatose patients still have to
be here
it's just that you know two wards
there'll be a generator
the rest of the hospital will be
completely and utterly dark and we have
a skeleton staff here
just to make sure that everything's all
right so that's
what she gets roped into doing
as like i said as sort of a punishment
for undermining the matrons authority
now you don't find out why until later
on uh which i'm not going to spoil
because like i said there's a very very
very new
film and so i don't want to you know do
any spoilers or anything like that
but valerie is terrified of the dark uh
they do have a couple
of flashes as to why that might be
although as i said it doesn't really
come clear until later on so basically
she is stuck in this hospital
with only a few other people there's
three other nurses i believe
uh two of whom are friendly but they're
sort of like take this job and shove it
types
uh one of the girls she had actually
gone to nursing school with
and that girl is like kind of a [ __ ]
and also there is some reference to
something that val did back when she was
at school and got a reputation about
and like i said that also ties into the
main story although you don't find out
exactly what happened until later on and
it ties into
you know the [ __ ] that's going on at the
hospital as well because it's all kind
of like thematically linked
so uh so basically she's there and then
there's like a guy that's sort of like a
security guard type of guy and he's kind
of a skeeze
so there's all that [ __ ] going on and
there's also like one little patient who
keeps
like escaping every her name is uh saba
and she doesn't really speak
much english so into this kind of creepy
hospital setting you know this little
mousy girl that's afraid of the dark
these other kind of nurses that are sore
over because they've done been you know
they've done this before so it's no big
deal to them
so she starts to experience the
trappings of
uh what is commonly known as a haunting
you know she kind of sees it
starts out very small where she's sort
of walking through a ward you know all
the lights go out the generator doesn't
come on or the generator goes off or
whatever and then like she starts
feeling something like tugging at the
back of her dress there's nothing there
all this other kind of stuff and then
she starts
sort of seeing things um there's also
kind of this weird ash
that's sort of coming out of the the
great or whatever and she kind of sees
it on some of the comatose patients
hands and it's like a little bit weird
so she's kind of like creeped out by all
of this and
as the movie goes on i will okay so this
is kind of like
it's a haunted hospital thing but
it also has a large possession element
to it as well
which i'm not sure if i really liked
that
angle as much because i do kind of feel
like it had it was you know
very tropey as far as like possession
goes you know you had the whole floating
in the air the whole
you know doing crazy back bends and that
kind of stuff
um so it does kind of go in that
direction i think that i
liked the movie better in the first
half when it was more atmospheric it
kind of gave me
a sort of vibe like maybe session 9 or
the others
or the orphanage or anything like that
that's just kind of like this big
institutional building that's empty and
are largely empty and dark and there may
or may not be something creeping around
in there
and so i think that all that kind of
[ __ ] and then like all the kind of [ __ ]
about
you know her relationship with the other
nurses her relationship with this
you know skeezy guy her relationship
with this doctor
this other girl that she knew before and
this whole thing about her past like
what was going on with that
that was like really intriguing and i
really liked that like i said the way
it's shot
i can't remember the name of the
cinematographer i think it was jennifer
something but i can't remember her last
name i apologize for that
but uh i really liked the cinematography
the look of it is there was something
like really appealing
of it to me it's very you know it's very
british 1970s
so it's very subdued but
i don't know there was something about
it that i really liked um and and i
really liked the way
her like val's very very crisp
uh buttoned-up uniform at the beginning
was almost kind of contrasted against
kind of this crappy looking
hospital you know what i mean it was
sort of this ramshackle looking
thing with like these kind of terrible
paintings on the wall of the children's
ward and stuff not creepy but they were
just like not really
very well done but as i said because
this movie is so
new it's kind of hard for me to discuss
too much about what's going on
because i don't really want to spoil it
if you want to watch it i would
recommend it
um like i said i don't usually do kind
of star ratings or anything like that
but if i had to it's a it was a middle
of the road i mean i found it a
compelling
you know haunting type story uh like i
said i think i liked the build up of it
better than
the second half when it went when it
went more into like a straight out
it's not possession in the sense of like
demon possession but it's sort of it's a
ghost story but there is a possession
element to it
um and i i did like that and i liked the
resolution i kind of liked
i i don't know i guess i liked the the
theme of it i liked the message of it
because like i said you know the power
the the title
doesn't just refer to the electricity
the rolling blackouts but it also refers
to
sort of the power structure of this
hospital
of society at large particularly in this
time period so you there is some of that
in there and i liked that
aspect of it as well i did find a lit
the middle of it a little bit confusing
like for a little bit
i wasn't really sure what was going on
you know what i mean because i think
they kind
of they they strung some clues along as
to
what was happening what had happened to
her in the past you know uh that was
that made her afraid of the dark what
had happened in the past that made
uh this other nurse like this friend of
hers like be so [ __ ] toward her why
she had a reputation
you know so it did resolve itself later
on but for a little while in the middle
i was kind of like well wait a minute
what does that mean what what's going on
with this but it did resolve itself in
the end
i did like too that they kind of left it
you know as much as i said that i was a
little confused in the middle but
as i said that i did resolve that did
resolve itself later
but i liked for a long time it was sort
of because i
you know i'm a big fan of ambiguity so i
really like that it was kind of
ambiguous
as to whether the hospital was really
haunted
um whether this ghost was really there
whether that person was still alive
whether val just had these emotional
problems that were
you know causing her to see these things
or causing her to freak out because she
was so stressed out because of the
darkness and the new job
and how everyone was treating her and
stuff so i do kind of like that
that that whole thing was going on in
there too which like i said it probably
contributes to
why i wasn't a huge fan of it going like
full-on possession at the end
but you know or towards the end but you
know that said like i said it's
a solid you know three star watch if you
like real atmospheric british
ghost story type films like i said
anything like
you know that's set in an institution
that's empty if you like that kind of
[ __ ]
then you will probably dig this it's a
it's a perfectly
entertaining film it's a subdued like i
said it's
you know it's a it's a british ghost
story it's not like action-packed or
anything
but i really i liked all the acting i
really liked the interactions between
the characters i think that was probably
my favorite part of it was like all the
character work
and i really liked uh kind of the
exploration of the power dynamic
particularly in this hospital
uh you know the kind of you know where
the where all the doctors were all
these kind of creepy old men and like
all the nurses were like these young
women and
how it was sort of like you know the
power dynamic the gender dynamic so i
really really liked that aspect of it
but you know it's not reinventing the
wheel as far as you know haunted
hospital movies go as far as possession
movies go
it had kind of a lot of the same trophy
kind of stuff not a lot of jump scares
which i appreciated but yeah
it was just like a good middle of the
road atmospheric
type you know british ghost story and if
that sounds like something that you
would
uh like then probably you should watch
it because i you know i dug it i had a
good time
watching it i wasn't bored at any point
it you know kept me interested up until
the end
i was interested in the mystery in
resolving what had gone on with her past
and everything like that
so as i said this is a very very new
movie 2021
it's on shutter at the moment presumably
in all english-speaking countries at
least in the us it is and i'm assuming
it's uk and australia as well
so if it sounds good to you uh then go
and check it out and let me know
what you thought about it in the
comments and i will see you on the next
one
bye